Prof: Okay,
so now we have a number of
different perspectives we can
take on understanding what holds
molecules together;
that is, on bonding.
We can look at the real
molecule, for example,
with X-ray.
Or we can do a computer
calculation,
and if we do a careful enough
computer calculation,
we can get something that we
believe is pretty close to
reality,
like the total electron density
I showed you.
Right?
And the goal of the computer is
to approximate the
Schrödinger equation.
You can't do it absolutely,
but you can,
depending on how much computer
power you want to throw at it,
you can do it close enough for
most purposes.
Okay.
But you're neither the molecule
-- well you are a molecule --
but you're neither the kind of
molecule we're studying,
nor are you a computer.
You're a chemist,
and your goal is to understand
things;
let the computer do the heavy
lifting mathematically and you
understand it.
Okay, so let's see if we can
understand some of the things
that we didn't understand when
we were looking at the molecule
really,
with X-ray diffraction. Right?
When we were looking,
we looked at this molecule and
said that the bonding,
from the Lewis point of view,
was pathological.
And you remember how we saw
that.
We looked at a cross-section
through those three atoms,
and it looked like that in the
electron difference density.
And you remember what's funny
about it?
What's pathological?
Dana?
Student:  The bonds
appear to be bent.
Prof: Some of the bonds
are bent, and what else?
Student:  And there's
another bond that's missing.
Prof: And one bond is
missing.
So that bond isn't there in the
electron density,
the difference density.
And those are bent.
They don't lie on the line
between the nuclei.
Now, can we understand that,
from the point of view of
molecular orbitals,
of Schrödinger's equation;
why it should look like that in
this particular case?
So would a computer's molecular
orbitals provide understanding?
So I was just showing you,
as the class assembled,
how you get these molecular
orbitals, and I was showing you
some of them.
There's the framework of the
molecule superimposed on this
map, and that triangle on top
there, on the right,
is what we're looking at.
And so we could look at the
thirty-second of the
thirty-three occupied orbitals,
the next to the highest
occupied orbital,
and it looks like that.
That's the one we were just
looking at, before we went on to
the PowerPoint.
And you see there is electron
density in those -- the
wavefunction has big value in
the region where those bonds are
bent.
But there are thirty-three of
these occupied orbitals,
and they put electron density
every which way,
and it's very difficult to
understand why this is
the way it is,
why it's bent.
Even if you grant -- which is
not easy to grant --
that this is the proper orbital
to look at,
and that indeed the electron
density of the red and blue,
big red and blue lobes,
are not on the line between;
we don't know why they are.
Right?
And there's so much other
electron density in the
molecule, with all complicated
nodes, that it's very difficult
to know where to look.
Right?
So the answer is no,
it doesn't provide
understanding.
It gives far too complicated an
answer.
It doesn't tell you why.
Even if you believe that it
gives you the right numbers,
it doesn't tell you why.
Okay?
But analysis in terms of
pairwise --
that is, don't go over the
whole molecule,
just look at two atoms adjacent
to one another,
making a bond,
so just a very local view --
pairwise bonding overlap of
hybrid atomic orbitals explains
these two pathologies.
So let's look.
First, I will assert that the
best overlap you can get between
hybrid orbitals on these carbons
--
if the nuclei are arranged in
an equilateral triangle,
so 60º angles -- the best
hybrids you can get point at the
angles shown by the red arrows
here.
They do it in order to get the
best overlap.
Now this seems funny,
because the angle between the
red arrows on the right carbon
is greater than 90º.
Why do I say it's funny that
it's greater than --
you're not going to be able to
make it 60º
because two orbitals that made
a 60º angle would not be
independent orbitals.
Obviously if they were right on
top of one another,
they'd be the same orbital.
But you can't say they're not
the same orbital if they're just
a little bit away,
because still they're mostly
the same orbital.
It's only once they get to
90º that they can be
different.
What would the orbitals be that
would be independent of one
another at 90º?
Students:
p orbitals.
Prof: p orbitals,
right?
So 90º is the smallest
angle you could get.
Why don't you use 90º?
Why do you use greater than
90º?
Okay, that's the question.
Why not use p orbitals
and make the smallest angle you
can?
Does anybody see why that is?
Okay here, there's a p
orbital that points at 90º.
You see its axis,
the yellow axis,
is a little bit inside the red
arrow,
and the blue axis,
which would be another p
orbital,
perpendicular to that one,
is a little inside the other
red arrow;
they make an angle of 90º.
Got it?
Now why don't the atoms use
p orbitals to make the
smallest possible angle?
Can anybody see why that won't
give the best overlap?
How could you change the
orbital so as to get better
overlap?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: Claire?
Student:  The best
overlap is between an s
and a p orbital.
So if it's two p
orbitals, you don't have the
best overlap.
Prof: Remember,
that depends on the distance.
And they're very close to one
another.
And it turns out it might be
that at this angle --
if you used the s on one
of the carbons,
and the p on another --
it might be that you would get
better overlap.
I don't know that it's true,
but it's not implausible.
But what would be wrong about
using this p orbital from
that carbon,
and on the top one of the
triangle using an s,
which might give better overlap?
Can you see what's bad about
that?
If you use all the s of
that top carbon there,
you can't use any of it to make
any of the other bonds from that
carbon.
Right?
All you have left over on that
one is p's,
which give crummy overlap.
So even though you might be
able make this single overlap
better, you couldn't make all
the bonds strong from that top
carbon.
So you wouldn't get the best
overall overlap.
So that's a good suggestion.
But there's another way to do
it, which is to use a hybrid
orbital.
Now here we've put in a little
bit less than 20% of s,
to give the ratio
sp^4.1.
Right?
But notice that it really
distorted;
it made it much larger in the
region where we're interested in
it overlapping.
Right?
In the process,
the axis moved out,
to close to where the red arrow
is.
Right?
But even though the bonds
didn't point -- let's see,
like this -- even though the
bonds didn't point at one
another, by extending they
overlap more.
Got the idea?
So the hybridization,
by shifting it to one side,
gives better overlap,
even though the angle might not
be quite as good.
So you have bent bonds,
paradoxically enough,
in order to get the best
overlap.
Isn't that funny?
You'd think the best overlap
would be when they'd point at
one another.
But you get it better when they
make an angle because they
stretch out.
Okay, so that explains the bent
bonds.
Now how about the missing bond?
Well again we can see that in
hybridization.
Because what's left over,
after you make those
sp^4.1's,
three of them,
pointing up from the bottom
carbon,
after you make three
sp^4.1's,
what you have left over is an
sp^1.4.
And it points down, not up.
If it pointed up,
if the big blue lobe were up
and the red down,
then it would be part of those
other three orbitals.
The only way you can make it
point up is to make the others
point down.
Right?
And then they would have crummy
overlap.
So there's very poor overlap
between the tiny lobes of these
two.
So there's not enough overlap
to get a bond.
You don't stabilize the
electrons because you don't have
overlap.
Right?
And rehybridizing this one,
to strengthen this particular
bond,
by making it point up,
would drastically weaken all
the others,
making them point down. Right?
So the best overall overlap,
for all the pairs that are
involved in these bonds,
is to have one bond not there,
or to have very,
very poor overlap so that the
other three are very good.
Sam?
Student:  So when you
hybridized the other two and you
get the sp^4.1,
shouldn't -- and I understand
that shifts the electrons
towards the other atom,
but how does that shifting
distort the angle?
Prof: Remember the angle
between hybrids depends on
m and n;
sp^m^( )and sp^n,
we did that last time.
If it's pure p,
it's 90º.
If it's sp^3_,
-sp^3,
it's 109.5.
If it's
sp^2_,-
sp^2_ it's 120;
and so on.
If it's sp^4.1,
it makes that certain angle
that's shown there bigger than
90º.
Okay?
And the only reason for that is
so that these hybrids will be
different from one another;
they won't be the same. Right?
They won't overlap each other
on the same atom,
because to the extent they do,
they're the same,
and so they can't at all.
They have to be orthogonal,
if they're on the same atom.
Okay, now three views of BH_3.
First nature;
the total electron density.
I'm going over the same thing
again and again here,
with different examples.
First look at total electron
density; nature.
Then we'll look at molecular
orbitals;
that's what a computer does.
And then we'll look at bonds
from hybrid atomic orbitals;
and that's what we do,
as chemists.
Okay, first we'll look at the
electron cloud of BH_3,
calculated here,
using that same program I just
showed you.
So we can look at the
successive layers of the onion,
the high electron density,
lower, lower,
lower, the various contours.
So this lowest one is mostly
1s of boron,
but a little bit of the
1s's of hydrogen too.
And one of them doesn't even
show up, because it's so small.
All the hydrogens should be the
same,
but the graphing capability of
the computer,
for something that has as few
points as this,
the way it draws surfaces,
doesn't draw them smooth.
Right?
It connects points,
so it doesn't even show one of
those.
Nobody would ever make such a
plot.
Okay?
That's 0.3 electrons per cubic
angstrom.
So suppose we go to 0.15
electrons per cubic angstrom,
half that density.
Now we're beginning to get
smoother surfaces.
And it's on the boron,
it's 1s of the boron,
and a little bit of the
hydrogens as well.
Right?
And now we're going to lower
the electron density,
0.05.
And now there's an interesting
feature you can see here.
You see that dimple?
Why is that?
Why is there not as much
electron density,
at this level,
around the boron?
We're out in the valence-shell
now;
not 1s anymore,
because the 1s is really
down close, high density.
It's because the hydrogen atoms
are pulling the electron density
away from the valence atoms of
Boron.
Often you talk about this in
terms of electronegativity.
But why is something
electronegative?
It's because of what the
effective nuclear charge is.
The effective nuclear charge of
hydrogen, for the valence level,
is one.
Right?
But for boron it should be
higher.
Boron is the fifth element.
But it's got the 1s
electrons shielding the nucleus.
So it's not as high an
effective nuclear charge as
hydrogen does.
So when you put the orbitals
together, hydrogen is lower than
boron, and the electrons,
in those bonds,
are mostly on the hydrogen.
So you see that dimple in the
middle, because there's not much
valence electron density on the
boron.
Now we go to 0.02 electrons per
cubic angstrom;
and finally to 0.002 electrons
per cubic angstrom,
which is defined as (for
purposes of drawing what the van
der Waals surface is,
that is) how close molecules
tend to get to one another at
normal pressure in a liquid or
in a crystal.
Right?
And that's, it's just found
empirically,
just by testing and measuring
things,
that if you draw a surface at
0.002 electrons per cubic
Angstrom,
you have about how close things
would come to one another when
you bump these surfaces into one
another.
Okay, so that's the van der
Waals surface;
that's a definition, right?
And we showed once before
electrostatic potential,
where you show that same
surface but color it,
to show how the electrons are
distributed,
and the protons in the molecule.
So where would a positive
charge on the surface be happy?
Where it's negative.
That's red.
And where would it be unhappy,
the positive charge,
because the molecule is
positive there?
That's the blue.
So you can see what it is.
It's red where the hydrogens
are, because they're pulling the
electrons, and it's blue where
the boron is,
because it's giving up
electrons.
Okay, so there's what the real
molecule looks like.
Of course I didn't do it by an
experimental measurement from
BH_3, because you can't
crystallize BH_3.
I did it by a computer
calculation.
But I believe that what it
gives is what you would see in
an experiment,
if you could do the experiment.
Okay, so that's the total
electron density.
Now let's look at how the
computer breaks that up into
molecular orbitals in a
calculation like this.
So it looks at -- it makes
symmetrical molecular orbitals,
like Chladni things,
with nodes;
we've seen lots of those.
So here's the framework,
BH_3, and we're going to look
at the molecular orbitals the
computer calculates.
And we're going to make those
molecular orbitals by adding up
atomic orbitals,
linear combination of atomic
orbitals.
And which atomic orbitals will
we use?
The best would be if we used
every atomic orbital.
Then we could get perfect
flexibility, but the calculation
would take too long.
So we use just a minimal number
of atomic orbitals;
namely the 1s orbital on
boron,
and also the valence orbitals,
2s,
2p_x,
2p_y,
2p_z,
and also the 1s orbitals
of hydrogen.
So there are one,
two, three, four,
five, six, seven,
eight, there are eight atomic
orbitals we're going to use,
to make up our molecular
orbitals.
How many independent molecular
orbitals can we make,
if we start with eight atomic
orbitals?
We can make eight molecular
orbitals, the same number you
started with.
If you tried to make more,
they wouldn't be independent of
one another.
But you can make -- from eight,
you make eight.
Okay, so these are going to be
the energies that'll turn out of
the eight molecular orbitals
that we're going to get,
that the computer is going to
get, starting from that.
If you added more atomic
orbitals, if you let it use
3s,
3p, 3d,
and so on, then you'd get more
molecular orbitals,
but they'd be higher in energy,
and less relevant.
Okay?
In fact, how many of these are
relevant?
How do we know how many we care
about, the energy of?
Russell?
Student:  The total
number of electrons.
Prof: How many electrons.
We can put two electrons into
each.
Once we've got it filled up,
we don't really care what other
energies there could be;
at least not for this purpose.
Okay, well, it turns out that
boron has five electrons,
hydrogen has three;
eight altogether.
So there'll be eight electrons,
four pairs, and that means four
occupied orbitals.
We don't care so much about the
others, right?
So those are the Occupied
Molecular Orbitals,
OMO.
Okay?
And then there'll be,
also from this set of atomic
orbitals, there'll be four
Unoccupied Molecular Orbitals,
UMOs.
Okay, now those two are called
-- nobody talks about OMO and
UMO,
but they talk about HOMO --
that's very important and we'll
be talking about that --
that's the Highest Occupied
Molecular Orbital.
And also they're very
interested in the Lowest
Unoccupied Molecular Orbital;
and you'll see why very shortly.
So the LUMO and the HOMO are
very important.
In this particular case it
turns out there are two HOMOs
that have the same energy.
Not surprisingly,
because it's such a symmetrical
molecule.
Okay now, what do you think the
very lowest orbital looks like?
Katelyn, you're our expert.
What?
Student:  1s.
Prof: It's the 1s
orbital of boron.
So there it is.
No surprise there.
Not to diminish your
contribution,
but it's not surprising.
Okay, so there's 1s.
That's the boron core.
Now what's going to come next
do you think?
After we've got the 1s
molecular orbital,
what'll be next?
Students:  2s.
Prof: 2s.
But it's a molecular orbital,
it'll be made up of everything.
So here it is, right?
And it's all the hydrogens and
also the boron 2s are
contributing to that.
Again there's a dimple in the
middle, more of the hydrogens
than of the boron.
Why?
Because the hydrogen 1s
is lower than the boron
2s.
The boron 1s was lower;
that was the first one, right?
Okay.
And then, so there's that
radial node, the spherical sort
of node down the middle,
showing it's a 2s.
Right?
And then there's a 2p_x
molecular orbital,
and a 2p_y molecular
orbital.
And that's four,
and that's all eight electrons.
So that's what we care about.
They're the occupied molecular
orbitals of BH_3.
Now how about the vacant
orbitals?
The lowest unoccupied orbital
is the last 2p,
the 2p_z,
that's pointing in and out of
the plane of the molecule.
And then we're going to have
3s, which you see has
that node in the middle;
so two spherical sort of nodes.
And then a d_x^2-y^2,
and finally d_xy.
Right?
So that's the molecular
orbitals that the computer
generates for this thing,
using what's called a
"minimal basis set";
that is, the lowest number of
orbitals you can use to get --
that is, through the valence
level;
you don't put the higher ones
in.
Okay, now that's how the
computer does it.
Right?
And you can get good numbers
out of the computer,
like the energy of the
molecule, or the shape of the
molecule,
where the nuclei would like to
be to minimize the energy.
That's fine,
but for understanding it's not
so good.
What we want to do,
as chemists to understand it,
is to partition the total
electron density,
not into these molecular
orbitals, but into atom-pair
bonds,
and anti-bonds,
as you'll see,
and lone pairs;
the same stuff Lewis talked
about.
Okay.
That is, we usually do this,
but sometimes it doesn't work.
And when doesn't it work?
When it doesn't work,
we must use more sophisticated
orbitals, where we say there is
a certain phenomenon going on.
You know what that phenomenon
is?
When we can't use localized
bonds?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: That's what
resonance is,
when this approach doesn't
work.
Okay, remember that's where
Lewis Theory had to get sort of
complicated, Baroque.
Okay, so there's that
2p_z orbital,
a vacant orbital.
Right?
Here's the boron core.
But now we're doing it.
We're happy to use a vacant
orbital.
That's part of Lewis's idea.
So 2p_z we'll share with
the computer;
both of us see that as a lowest
vacant orbital.
The boron core we understand
quite well.
Okay?
But how are we going to treat
those other three pairs of
electrons, in the picture Lewis
would draw?
Where would Lewis put those
three pairs of dots?
Angela?
Can't hear.
Student:  He'd make them
the bonds between --
Prof: Those would be the
bonds, between B and H.
Okay?
So what will those look like in
our crummy picture?
Right?
We're not as good,
at least I'm not as good as the
computer at drawing these
things.
But what I'd say,
it's going to be an orbital
that's big on hydrogen,
smaller on boron;
some hybrid sp^2 hybrid
of boron is going to overlap
with the 1s orbital of
hydrogen.
It's going to be bigger on
hydrogen than on boron.
Why?
Why should the lowest,
the bonding orbital,
be bigger on hydrogen than on
boron?
Lucas?
Student:  The 1s
is more shielding.
Prof: Yes.
That's another -- that that
orbital, the hydrogen orbital,
is lower in energy than the
boron it's mixing with.
Right?
So it's uneven mixing. Right?
Poor energy match.
So the one that went down looks
mostly like the hydrogen,
and the one that went up looks
mostly like the boron.
So we see one -- in fact,
we see three of these,
one pointing toward each
hydrogen.
Right?
From our point of view they all
have the same energy,
they're all B-H bonds,
shown as their energy in red
there.
Okay?
But notice, you get the same
total energy,
as the computer would.
The computer divides the pie
completely differently.
Right?
But you get the same answer --
right?
-- and the same geometry that
the computer does,
from the point of view of what
direction do the hybrids point
and so on.
So we're getting the same
structure, we're getting the
same energy.
You get the same total electron
density too, if you add all the
electrons together.
Three bonds add together to
give the -- the same way,
remember, three p
orbitals added up together
to give a sphere.
Right?
Our three bonds add up to give
the same energy as the computer.
So who needs a computer? Right?
Our bonds work just as well,
if we view them right.
Okay?
And then there would be the
anti-bond, the one that's --
what's left over,
that's big on boron,
small on H, and a node between
hydrogen and boron;
it's antibonding,
the one that went up in energy
when the atoms came together.
And again there'd be three of
these Ïƒ*'s,
big on boron,
small on H.
They would all have the same
energy.
But again their average energy
is the same as the average
energy of unoccupied molecular
orbitals that the computer gets.
So we're not doing so bad,
following Lewis in this
respect,
looking at the electron density
in terms of bonds rather than in
terms of molecular orbitals.
Okay?
So for many purposes,
localized bond orbitals are not
bad, and they're certainly a
heck of a lot easier to think
about.
But, beware of resonance. Right?
Because sometimes this isn't
going to work.
So we'll have to understand how
that works.
So the localized bond orbital
picture, pairwise molecular
orbitals;
that is, two atoms coming
together to overlap.
And also there'll be isolated
atomic orbitals,
like unshared pairs,
or isolated vacant orbitals,
like the p_z orbital of
boron that we just saw,
that will be -- this picture
will be our intermediate between
hydrogen-like atomic orbitals,
which we really understand --
you just look up in the table
and you've got them,
right?
-- and computer molecular
orbitals, which are too
complicated really to understand
in any kind of detail.
It's handy to sometimes -- for
some purposes it's very handy to
be able to calculate them and
look at them,
right?
But you don't do it very often
in your head.
So when must we think more
deeply?
When you have these localized
orbitals, but they mix,
to cause reactivity;
that is, a molecular orbital
from this molecule mixes with a
molecular orbital from this
molecule, and one goes down and
one goes up.
That's what a reaction is.
Or when you have two pairwise
orbitals in the same molecule,
that we thought of as bonds or
vacant orbitals or something
like that,
and those interact with one
another,
within the same molecule.
We were too simplistic in
thinking of them as independent.
They interact with one another.
That's what resonance -- that's
when resonance occurs is when
you have important interactions
within a molecule,
between orbitals,
or between what you thought
were orbitals;
but were thinking too simply.
So where are we?
We've gone through atoms,
we've gone through molecules,
and looked at how we can
understand the electron density
in molecules.
And now we're to the final
payoff, which is reactivity.
How can we understand
reactivity in terms of SOMOs,
Singly Occupied Molecular
Orbitals, high HOMOs,
and low LUMOs?
And then how can we recognize
functional groups?
So even if we never saw them
before, we know how reactive
they're going to be,
and what with;
that's the payoff.
Okay, so now we know that if
you have two molecules and
you're interested in their
reacting,
there'll be molecular orbitals
of the two that come together,
interact.
And if the molecule gets -- if
the energy goes down because of
that, that'll be a favorable
reaction.
If the energy goes up,
they'll bounce off one another.
Okay?
So, but how many molecular
orbitals are there on a
molecule?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: Suppose methane,
how many molecular orbitals
does it have?
It has an infinite number,
right?
The 13z orbital and so
on.
Okay?
So we have to pick out which
orbitals are going to be
important in interacting with
one another,
or else we're just going to be
at a loss,
because there'll be so many.
So you have these orbitals on
molecule B, say,
and those are occupied,
and the ones above are vacant,
unoccupied.
And on molecule A you have a
bunch of occupied and a bunch of
unoccupied molecular orbitals.
And now we're going to look at
orbitals of B mixing with
orbitals of A. Right?
And which ones?
We might look at those two
interacting, for example,
mix those two,
between A and B.
Or we could mix those two,
or those two,
or those two --
and it goes up infinitely.
So this is a problem.
Even if we understand how
orbitals interact with one
another, we're going to have to
narrow our focus,
if we want to deal with this.
Okay?
So there are myriad possible
pairwise mixings.
Now there's one that's going to
be obviously important.
Suppose that molecule B has an
odd number of electrons,
and therefore a singly occupied
molecular orbital,
and the same is true of
molecule A;
just suppose that happens.
Right?
Then when they come together
and mix, those two electrons
will both go down in energy.
So that's bound to be
favorable, substantially
favorable, and you'll get a new
bond.
That's like two hydrogen atoms
coming together.
So if there are SOMOs,
on the two molecules -- and
notice, suppose B had a SOMO but
A didn't.
But you're not just talking
about two molecules,
you're talking about two
flasks.
If you mix -- you had to have
two B's that both had SOMOs.
So A could be another B.
So if you have any SOMOs,
you can pair them;
B with B, if A doesn't have
any.
Right?
So if they exist,
if there's a SOMO,
then -- and that's true of many
atoms,
or things called free radicals,
like the hydrogen atom,
the chlorine atom,
the methyl radical --
then they're going to be very
reactive.
Okay?
And for that very reason
they're not very common.
You can't buy a bottle of
methyl radicals because they
will all have reacted with one
another.
The same for hydrogen atoms,
the same for chlorine atoms.
So that's an easy case to
understand, when you have SOMOs.
But it's very rare to encounter
it, unless you're talking about
flames, where lots of things are
atoms and free radicals,
as they're called.
We'll talk about that a lot
more at the end of the semester.
Okay, now how about -- there
are two that could mix.
It's not bad energy match,
right?
And suppose they have good
overlap.
Do you care about that one?
Why not?
Lucas?
Student:  It doesn't
exist.
Prof: Oh it exists,
it's an orbital.
Student:  Oh,
there are no electrons.
Prof: There are no
electrons to have that energy.
It's an available energy,
but nobody availed themselves
of it.
So it doesn't contribute
anything.
Right?
So there's nothing there.
So forget that one.
And you can forget most of them
for this reason,
of the infinite number.
Okay, now how about this pair?
Now they have -- let's suppose
they have good overlap.
They're not bad energy match.
Right?
So two electrons will go down
and two will go up.
Do you care?
Steven?
Student:  No,
because since there's two that
are higher energy,
they're antibonding.
Prof: Yes.
So they'd more or less cancel.
Do they exactly cancel?
Students:  No.
Prof: In which direction
do they not cancel?
Corey?
Student:  The lower one
is bigger, so it would be even
worse.
Prof: The lower one is
bonding,
but bigger -- by bigger,
you mean greater than
1/âˆš2 kinds of
thing;
or no, pardon me,
less than 1/âˆš2,
it's smaller,
is what you should have said.
Okay, it's smaller.
So it doesn't go down as much
as the upper one goes up.
So pretty much they cancel.
But to the extent they don't
cancel, it's repulsive,
it's bad to come together,
which means the molecules will
bounce off.
Right?
So when you have filled
orbitals hitting one another,
the molecules repel one
another.
Okay?
So that's weak net repulsion.
That's not going to explain a
reaction.
Now how about here?
Now we're mixing a filled
orbital with a vacant orbital.
So two electrons go down.
So you don't have this
canceling.
Is this going to be important,
this one?
Josh?
Student:  No,
bad energy match.
Prof: Ah,
the energy match is so bad that
you don't get very much going
down;
not enough to make up for the
fact that if they'll come
together,
there are going to be a lot of
other orbitals,
molecular orbitals,
overlapping,
and they're going to be
repulsive,
the kind we just looked at.
So this weak attraction is not
going to be worth much.
So it's negligible mixing
because of bad energy match.
Now how about here?
Now that's not bad energy match;
I mean, it's not great energy
match, but it's certainly better
than any other pair of occupied
with vacant.
Okay?
So that means that pair will go
down -- right?
-- and you'll get bonding,
if the energy match is good
enough that the amount that they
go down is significant.
Okay?
So remember,
when we tried the same thing
the other direction,
from the highest one on the
right to the lowest one on the
left,
the energy match was not good.
So that didn't help.
But this one,
where it's high on the left and
low on the right,
that one will help.
Okay, so what it requires,
to have a reaction,
is that you have a high HOMO,
an unusually high HOMO,
on one molecule,
and an unusually low LUMO on
the other,
so that you have good energy
match,
or at least as good as you can
get.
Right?
Then you could get a reaction.
And it turns out that there are
simple names for things that
have unusually high HOMOs and
things that have unusually low
LUMOs.
And you know what those names
are?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: Something that has
an unusually high HOMO is called
a base,
and something that has an
unusually low LUMO is called --
Students:  Acid.
Prof: An acid. Right?
So that's a generalization of
the idea of acid and base.
Most mixing of MOs affects
neither the overall energy,
nor the overall electron
distribution,
for one or more of these
reasons.
Okay?
First the electron occupancy
can be four;
that is, both were occupied,
which means two go up and two
go down, and the ones that go
up, go up a little more.
So that's not a bond.
Or zero, and you don't care
about the energy.
Or the energy match is poor,
so there's not much mixing all
together.
Or there's poor overlap.
So even if the energy match
were good, you wouldn't get
anything out of it.
But, if you have high HOMO and
low LUMO mixing,
then you get reactivity;
unusually high HOMO and
unusually low LUMO.
And that's the secret we've
been going for all semester.
So here's increasing generality
in the concept of acid and base.
The names were introduced by
Lavoisier, in 1789,
and we'll talk about that.
And from his point of view,
a base was an element,
a substance that could be
oxidized, and an acid was
something that had been
oxidized.
Like sulfur was a base;
oxidized sulfur,
sulfuric acid,
was an acid.
Phosphorus was a base;
oxidized phosphorus was
phosphoric acid.
Carbon was a base;
oxidized carbon was carbonic
acid.
Okay?
Then 100 years later,
Arrhenius, in Sweden,
said that an acid was something
that was --
had the idea that there were
ions,
things that were charged,
and that a thing that would
give H^+ was an acid,
and a thing that would give
OH^- was a base.
That's Arrhenius's Theory.
And that was further
generalized, in 1923,
by Brønsted and Lowry --
Brønsted was a Dane and
Lowry an Englishman --
who said that an acid was an
H^+ donor --
that's the same as Arrhenius --
but that a base was something
that could accept H^+;
not only OH^-,
but ammonia,
for example,
could accept a base.
And Lewis then,
in the same year,
had the idea that an acid was
something that could accept an
electron pair,
like BH_3, and a base was
something that could donate an
electron pair,
like ammonia. Right?
And other names for those
acceptors and donors are
electrophile,
something that loves electrons,
will accept them;
and a nucleophile,
something that loves a nucleus,
is something that will give
electrons to it.
But in the 1960s this was
generalized finally to where it
is now, that an unusually low
vacant orbital is something that
can accept electrons;
electrons like to be in a low
energy orbital.
So that is the ultimate
definition of what an acid is.
And by the same token,
an unusually high HOMO has
electrons that are eager to
avail themselves of some vacant
orbital, to lower their energy;
and that is a base.
Okay?
So as so often in science,
as the science matures,
you get more and more
generality to the idea.
And HOMO and LUMO,
unusually high HOMO,
unusually low LUMO,
are the ultimate form of
acid-base;
and that's what we'll be
talking about.
But they have to be unusual.
Why do they have to be
unusually high and unusually
low?
Prof: Because otherwise
you don't have good energy
match, to change the electron
energies when they come
together.
Okay, now here's what you
should have asked.
Unusual: compared to what?
Okay?
So here is what -- we're
organic chemists.
If we were some other kind of
chemists in some other universe,
dealing with different
elements, we'd have different
points of comparison.
But what we deal with is things
that have a lot of carbon and
hydrogen in them.
And by far our most common
bonds are among -- between
carbons, or between carbon and
hydrogen.
So it turns out that the
valence orbitals of carbon,
the sp hybrid orbitals
of carbon,
and the 1s orbital of
hydrogen,
are roughly the same in energy.
For our purposes we'll consider
them to be the same.
Okay?
So you bring two of these
together, they overlap,
and you get Ïƒ and
Ïƒ*.
And we've talked about that,
the bonding and the antibonding
orbital.
So most of the occupied
orbitals we're dealing with are
Ïƒ_CC or
Ïƒ _CH,
and most of the anti-bonding
orbitals are Ïƒ*_CH
or Ïƒ*_CC.
So those are our point of
comparison.
Those are the plain vanilla
electrons and holes.
Okay?
Now let's look at other things
and see whether they're unusual
with respect to this.
Now there will be several
classes that they fall into.
Right?
So those are the usual LUMO and
the usual HOMO,
or the CC analogs.
Now what could make things
weird?
One thing could make things
weird is that if you had
valence-shell atomic orbitals,
that didn't get mixed with
anything.
So they're not Ïƒ
or Ïƒ*,
bonding or antibonding;
they're the original orbital,
in between these.
So that would make things
unusual.
A second one would be a little
bit in between these two.
If there's no overlap,
then you have unmixed orbitals.
If there's a lot of overlap,
you get bonds.
But there could be poor
overlap, in which case you don't
go down as far with your bonding
orbital, or up as far with your
anti-bonding orbitals.
So a second case would be poor
overlap.
A third case would be that the
actual atomic energy,
the atomic orbital energy that
you're using,
the atom you're using,
is not like carbon and
hydrogen.
So it starts at a completely
different place from where the
standard orbitals start,
before they make the molecular,
the bonding orbitals.
And fourth can be if there's
charge around.
Because obviously if you have a
negative charge,
it's not such a good place to
put electrons;
that means the orbitals are
high in energy.
If you have a net positive
charge, it's a good place to put
electrons;
it's low in energy.
So charge can make it.
So we're going to show examples
of these four contributors that
will allow you to identify when
a molecule has an unusual
orbital energy.
Right?
Unusually high HOMO,
unusually low LUMO.
And then you know that it'll be
a functional group,
and you also know what it'll
react with.
Because if you have an
unusually high HOMO,
it'll react with an unusually
low LUMO;
and vice versa.
Okay, so first let's look at
the first one,
unmixed valence-shell atomic
orbitals.
So H^+, Arrhenius's acid. Right?
That's a vacant orbital. Right?
No electron in it.
So that's obviously unusually
low.
It's where this started,
the 1s of hydrogen,
before it went up or down.
So if you had H^+,
it would be an unusually low
vacant orbital.
How about NH_3? Right?
It has an unshared pair,
only on the nitrogen.
Now, it likes being on
nitrogen, compared to carbon or
hydrogen.
Why?
What makes it better to be on
nitrogen,
in a valence-shell orbital than
on --
the unshared pair -- than to be
on an unshared pair on carbon or
on hydrogen?
Angela?
Student:  There's more
protons in nitrogen.
Prof: There are more
protons in the nucleus.
It's a lower energy orbital,
to start with.
Right?
But it didn't mix with anything.
There are N-H bonds,
in ammonia.
Right?
And they mixed and went way
down in energy,
and a vacant orbital went up in
energy.
But the unshared pair didn't
mix with anything.
So it still has that original
energy.
So it's unusually high.
Compared to what?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: Ïƒ_CH
or Ïƒ_CC.
That's our point of comparison.
Okay, or the flip side of that
is BH_3, which has a vacant
orbital.
It's high, to start with,
compared with a hydrogen or a
carbon, because boron doesn't
have a very big nuclear charge.
Right?
And its nucleus is screened.
So it's unusually high for an
atom.
But it's still atomic,
it didn't mix with anything and
go up further.
Right?
So it's unusually low for a
vacant orbital.
So BH_3 is an unusually low
LUMO.
So is it an acid or a base?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Student:  An acid.
Prof: Which?
Student:  Both.
Prof: I can't hear you.
Prof: You've read
through the lecture.
You don't get to vote
>
It's like H^+, right?
An unusually low LUMO.
So it's an acid.
How about NH_3?
It's a base,
unusually high HOMO.
Okay, how about water? Right?
It has unshared pairs of
electrons.
Yes Lucas?
Student:  Sort of a side
question.
Didn't we just say that they
both had these properties
because they had low nuclear
charge?
Prof: No,
nitrogen has high -- which has
low nuclear?
Student:  Nitrogen is,
low nuclear charge compared to
carbon.
Prof: Yes.
Student:  And BH_3 is
even lower, compared to carbon.
Prof: Yes.
Student:  But the
energies are completely
different because it's -- is it
just because of the unshared
pair?
Prof: But remember,
you have to bear in mind which
row of the periodic table you're
in.
Right?
H, true, it only has one
proton, but you're talking a
1s orbital,
low in energy.
For carbon, nitrogen,
oxygen, boron,
you're talking 2s.
Right?
So you're changing the game.
Student:  Between
BH_3_ and NH_3?
Prof: No,
no, not between BH_3_
and NH_3.
NH_3 is unusually high energy
for an occupied orbital.
BH_3 is unusually low;
although it's high,
compared to nitrogen,
it's low for a vacant orbital.
It's an unusually low LUMO.
Nitrogen's an unusually high
HOMO.
Now oxygen is lower than
nitrogen.
So water is a base.
But it's not as good a base as
ammonia, because its electrons
aren't as high,
because it has a bigger nuclear
charge, and the same n;
it's in the first complete row
in the periodic table.
Okay, OH^- is even higher.
It's a stronger base than water.
Why?
Why are its electrons higher in
energy than water?
Student:  Less protons.
Prof: Got less protons.
Right?
It's got a net negative charge,
which makes all the electrons
high in energy;
and specifically the pair we
care about, the highest one,
unusually high,
because it's got a negative
charge.
<<Technical
adjustment>>
Okay, CH_3^- is even more of a
base, because carbon doesn't
have as many -- as big a nuclear
charge as oxygen.
So when it has a negative
charge it's a really high HOMO.
Okay, I got to quit there.
We'll go on to two,
three and four next time.